I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello. Good. I always want to say good morning. I know you do because it's 9.30 a.m. for us. And I'm having a cup of tea. I'm having a cup of coffee. Hi guys! Today we are talking about two weeks, which is season five, episode 21, written by Aaron Shore and directed by Paul Lieberstein. As we were warming up today here in the
我是珍娜·菲舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你带来这档名为“终极办公室重温”的播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有亲历者才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。很好。我总是想说早上好。我知道你是这么想的，因为对我们来说现在是早上9点30分。我正在喝一杯茶。我正在喝一杯咖啡。大家好！今天我们要聊的是“两周”，也就是第五季第21集，由亚伦·舒尔编剧，保罗·利伯斯坦执导。今天我们在
studio, literally warming up because it was very cold. Yeah, it's freezing in here. And we were waiting for it to warm up. We were talking about how much we love writer Aaron Shore. Yes. Aaron, you are delightful. We are enjoying all your emails and just reconnecting with you. And you have the best stories. The best stories. It's no wonder they use so many stories from his real life in episodes. Here's a summary. At the end of the last episode, Michael told David Wallace he was quitting. And guess what? It's true. Yeah. He has given his official two weeks notice. And he has also given up on doing any work. Have you ever given a
工作室暖身时，真的是在暖身，因为非常冷。是的，这里冷得要命。我们在等它变暖和。我们谈到了我们有多么喜爱编剧亚伦·舒尔。是的。亚伦，你太可爱了。我们很喜欢你发的所有电子邮件，也很高兴能重新和你联系。你总是有最棒的故事。最棒的故事。难怪他们在剧集中用了那么多他真实生活中的故事。下面是剧情梗概。上一集结束时，迈克尔告诉大卫·华莱士他要辞职了。你猜怎么着？这是真的。是的。他正式提交了离职前两周的通知。而且他也彻底放弃工作了。你曾经递交过
two weeks notice? I have. So have I. It's the most awkward two weeks when you're at your job, but everyone knows you're quitting. Yes. And it's true. You kind of coast. I mean, I didn't walk around with, you know, scotch and splendor, but you kind of phone it in. Well, I gave two weeks notice at a job. And in that two weeks, it was my job to hire my replacement and train them. So I had to conduct interviews and put out a job posting and then create a handbook for my job for the next person. You had to do more work. I did. I did more work in my two weeks than ever before. I remember giving two weeks notice. And then when I
两周的离职通知吗？我交过。我也交过。当你还在公司工作，但所有人都知道你要离职时，那两周是最尴尬的。是的。确实如此。你基本上就是在混日子。我的意思是，我没有拿着苏格兰威士忌和代糖到处晃悠，但你确实是在敷衍了事。好吧，我在一家公司交过两周通知。在那两周里，我的工作是招聘我的替代者并培训他们。所以我不得不进行面试，发布招聘信息，然后为下一个人创建我的工作手册。你得做更多的工作。是的。我在那两周里做的工作比以往任何时候都多。我记得我交了两周的通知。然后当我
was finally done with the two weeks, I got in my car and guess what came on the radio? What? I'm free. Free fall. And I was like, it's a sign. Is that how you felt? Yes. Like in a good way. Not a bad free fall, like a good free fall. Yeah. You were done with that job. Sounds like you didn't like it. I did not like it. And you know what? I was a little bit of Michael Scott during my two weeks. Well, Michael is going to take a turn when he learns how bad the current job market is. He suddenly starts to panic. And in the end, he is going to start his own paper company. And he's going to start by trying to recruit Dunder Mifflin employees to work with
终于熬完这两周，我坐上车，你猜收音机里放的是什么歌？什么歌？《自由落体》。当时我就觉得，这是一个征兆。你是这种感觉吗？对。是那种好的感觉。不是那种糟糕的自由落体，而是那种美好的自由落体。是的。你终于摆脱那份工作了。听起来你很不喜欢它。我确实不喜欢。你知道吗？在那两周里，我也有一点迈克尔·斯科特的影子。嗯，当迈克尔了解到目前的就业市场有多糟糕时，他的态度发生了转变。他突然开始惊慌失措。最后，他决定创办自己的纸业公司。他首先尝试招募邓德米夫林的员工来和他一起
him. But pretty much everyone says no. Except Pam. Pam is the only employee who is going to join Michael in his new adventure. The Michael Scott paper company. I love this runner. I do too. Fast fact number one. When I was looking at the script for this episode, it aired on March 26th, 2009. That was my sister's 30th birthday. That same year, I turned 35 or five years apart. And I remembered what we did for our birthdays to mark these milestone birthdays. What? All right. This is a story where my family back home is like, I cannot believe this is your life. And I always say this is not my life. This is a moment. This is like
干。但几乎所有人都拒绝了。除了帕姆。帕姆是唯一一个将加入迈克尔的新冒险的员工。迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。我很喜欢这条副线。我也是。趣味冷知识一。当我查看这一集的剧本时，它是在2009年3月26日播出的。那是我姐姐的30岁生日。同年，我35岁，我们相差五岁。我记得我们为了庆祝这些里程碑式的生日都做了什么。什么？好吧，这是一个让我老家的家人觉得“我真不敢相信这就是你的人生”的故事。而我总是说这不是我的人生。这只是一个时刻。这就像
a crazy thing that happened. A club in Vegas. I remember this. This club in Vegas. And I am so sorry. I cannot remember your name. Oh, no. I'm so sorry. Because I know so very little about clubbing in Vegas. But this one time in my life, this club in Vegas reached out and they said that they would fly out my friends, family, whoever, give us an all expense paid trip to Vegas, a dinner. I remember this, Jenna, because I had a little baby. Yes. And I couldn't go. You couldn't go. And then you're texting me from Vegas. So I flew out my sister and her husband. And then I flew out Lee's brothers and sister. So it was like all of the
拉斯维加斯的一个俱乐部里发生的一件疯狂的事情。我记得这个。拉斯维加斯的那家俱乐部。真的很抱歉。我不记得你们的名字了。哦，不。我很抱歉。因为我对拉斯维加斯的夜店文化知之甚少。但有一次在我的生活中，拉斯维加斯的这家俱乐部联系了我们，他们说他们会安排我的朋友、家人或任何人飞过去，给我们提供一次全包的拉斯维加斯之旅，还有晚餐。珍娜，我记得这个，因为我当时有个小婴儿。对。你没去成。你没去成。然后你还从拉斯维加斯给我发短信。所以我让我姐姐和她丈夫飞了过去。然后我还让李的兄弟姐妹们飞了过去。所以就像所有的
brothers and sisters in law met in Vegas and we partied hard. And it all kind of culminated in this club experience, which I'd never had before with bottle service, sparklers, sparklers and cupcakes with my picture on them. Crazy, crazy. I have to tell you. So I wasn't able to go. And then the next year, the same club. Oh my gosh, club in Vegas. We don't remember your name. We were so sorry. The same the next year. It was really fun. We'll figure it out and we'll definitely tag you in a photo in our stories. We'll figure it out. The next year, same club with like an accent on the E. Yes. Yes. Okay. So the next year,
小叔子和大姑子们在拉斯维加斯聚齐了，我们狠狠地狂欢了一场。这一切最终都在这家夜店体验中达到了高潮，这是我以前从未经历过的，有酒水套餐、冷光烟火、冷光烟火，还有印有我照片的纸杯蛋糕。太疯狂了，太疯狂了。我得告诉你。所以我没能去。然后第二年，同一家俱乐部。哦，天哪，拉斯维加斯的俱乐部。我们不记得你的名字了。我们真的很抱歉。第二年还是同一家。真的很有趣。我们会想办法的，我们肯定会在我们的快拍中@你。我们会弄明白的。第二年，还是那家俱乐部，那个E字母上有重音符号的。是的。没错。好吧，所以第二年，
the same club reached out to me and Mindy because Mindy's June 24th and I'm June 25th. And they said, we will throw you a joint birthday party in Vegas, fly you out the whole shebang. And Mindy and I were like, Oh my gosh, remember, Jenna talking about it? We should do it. Mindy, do you remember this? I remember this. And then whatever we couldn't do it because we just had too many moving parts, but there was a split second where Mindy and I were in here and makeup and we're like, should we go to Vegas for a birthday? Yeah. Oh my gosh, privé, privé. I think it's privé, privé. A delicious dinner, I have to say. Well,
同一家俱乐部联系了我和明迪，因为明迪的生日是6月24日，我是6月25日。他们说，我们要在拉斯维加斯为你们举办一个联合生日派对，包机接送你们，一条龙服务。明迪和我们当时都觉得，哦天哪，还记得珍娜说过这事吗？我们应该去的。明迪，你还记得吗？我记得。然后不管怎样，我们最后没去，因为有太多不确定的因素了，但曾经有那么一瞬间，我和明迪在化妆间里说，我们要不要去拉斯维加斯过生日？对。哦天哪，Privé，Privé。我想是Privé，Privé。不得不说，那是一顿美味的晚餐。好吧，
dang it, dang it. Casino club area. It was pretty dang cool. That's a great flashback. Moving along to fast fact number two, you mentioned Scotch and Splenda. Yeah. Tastes like Splenda gets you drunk like Scotch. Michael first mentioned this drink in season three cocktails when he was having drinks at David Wallace's house. That episode was written by Paul Lieberstein. This episode is directed by Paul Lieberstein. So Paul clearly loves his Scotch and Splenda. I found a recipe for Scotch and Splenda and I thought we should have it today. Shut up. You're not. Wait, I haven't had, I didn't have much of a
该死，该死。赌场夜店区。真的很酷。这是一个很棒的回忆。接下来是趣味冷知识二，你提到了苏格兰威士忌加代糖。是的。喝起来像代糖，醉得像苏格兰威士忌。迈克尔在第三季的《鸡尾酒会》中首次提到这款饮品，当时他在大卫·华莱士家里喝酒。那一集是由保罗·利伯斯坦编剧的。这一集是由保罗·利伯斯坦执导的。所以保罗显然很喜欢他的苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我找到了一份苏格兰威士忌加代糖的配方，我觉得我们今天应该尝尝。闭嘴。你不会的。等等，我没怎么吃，我没吃多少
breakfast. Here's Scotch. Oh my god, Jenna. Wait, Sam, did you know about this? Cassie? Cassie's getting the ice. Here's the Splenda. Cassie, did you guys know? I didn't. Okay. And then I found one pancake for breakfast, only one. I thought we could drink it out of our own office ladies glasses. I love these, look. Okay. Oh my gosh, everybody. You can have sprinkles. I'll have the teapot. Okay. Sam and Cassie can have some dundies. This is me opening the Splenda. Oh my gosh. All right. You guys, it is 9.57 in the morning. All right, so here's what you need. You need one packet of Splenda. Okay. Oh my gosh. Two ounces of Scotch and some ice. I mean, I
早餐。这就是苏格兰威士忌。哦天哪，珍娜。等等，萨姆，你知道这个吗？卡西？卡西去拿冰块了。这是代糖。卡西，你们知道吗？我不知道。好吧。然后我发现早餐只有一个煎饼，只有一个。我想我们可以用我们自己的“办公室女郎”杯子来喝。我喜欢这些，看。哦天哪，大家。你可以用茶壶款。我用茶壶。好吧。萨姆和卡西可以用丹迪奖杯款。这是我打开代糖。哦天哪。好吧，各位，现在是早上9点57分。好吧，你需要这些：你需要一包代糖。好吧。哦天哪。两盎司苏格兰威士忌和一些冰块。我的意思是，我
don't know what this is gonna taste like. We're gonna be here for a bit. All right, I'm gonna open the Scotch. It's really happening, guys. I thought this would be fun. Only Cassie knew because she had to get the ice. I was like, do they have ice here? Here we go. That's ice going in. Stirry, stirry. Okay. Just so you guys know, this is what my parents think my job is. No, don't say that. Here we go. I'm certain this is disgusting. We're gonna let you know. Is everyone ready? Wait one second. Drink responsibly. Okay, ready? Here we go. Everybody try it. Cheers. Cheers, everyone. Cheers. Oh my god, you guys, it's not bad. I don't hate it. I don't hate it. Yeah, Splenda,
不知道这会是什么味道。我们要在这里待上一会儿。好吧，我要打开苏格兰威士忌了。真的要发生了，伙计们。我觉得这会很有趣。只有卡西知道，因为她得去拿冰块。我当时想，他们这里有冰块吗？我们开始吧。冰块加进去了。搅拌，搅拌。好吧，为了让你们知道，这就是我父母认为我的工作内容。不，别这么说。我们开始吧。我确信这一定很难喝。我们会让你们知道的。大家都准备好了吗？等一下。理性饮酒。好吧，准备好了吗？我们开始吧。大家都尝尝。干杯。大家干杯。干杯。哦天哪，伙计们，不赖嘛。我不讨厌它。我不讨厌它。是的，代糖，
I don't have anything snarky to say. I don't hate it. It's really nice. I don't hate it. I would totally drink this if you served it to me at a bar. I am maybe gonna ask for this the next time I go out. It tastes like something Applebees would have. Okay, wait, Jenna, if If you ask for Scotch and Splenda at a bar, I hope it shuts down. Oh, we need to go to Chili's and ask for Scotch and Splenda. Yes. Oh, my lord. All right, guys.
我没什么刻薄的话要说。我不讨厌它。真的挺不错的。我不讨厌它。如果你在酒吧里端给我这个，我完全会喝。下次我出门时，我可能会点这个。它喝起来像是苹果蜂餐厅会有的东西。等等，珍娜，如果你在酒吧里点苏格兰威士忌加代糖，我希望那家酒吧直接倒闭。哦，我们得去奇利斯餐厅点苏格兰威士忌加代糖。是的。哦，天哪。好吧，伙计们。
Cheers. Cheers, everyone. All right. To chunking it. To chunking it. Sam, bringing back the chunk. Wow, it's really kind of good. Michael Scott was onto something.
干杯。大家干杯。好吧。为了这一口。为了这一口。萨姆，把这一口的味道找回来了。哇，其实还挺好喝的。迈克尔·斯科特确实有点眼光。
I truly believed it was going to be awful and I like it. I like it too. Some things we should do a spinoff podcast called Scotch and Splenda. I can't wait to see what we talk about on that podcast. All right. Fast fact number three. Shortly after this episode aired, the NBC office website sent out a mass email to all subscribers from Michael Scott about the fact that he was quitting Dunder Mifflin.
我原本坚信这一定会难喝得要命，但我其实挺喜欢的。我也挺喜欢的。有些事情我们应该去做一个衍生播客，就叫《苏格兰威士忌加代糖》。我等不及要看看我们在那个播客里会聊些什么了。好吧。趣味冷知识三。在这集播出后不久，NBC办公室网站向所有订阅者发送了一封来自迈克尔·斯科特的群发邮件，内容是他要离开邓德米夫林。
Yes. And this is what it said. It said, as the manager of Dunder Mifflin Scranton, I learned two things. Everything about the paper business and that Dunder Mifflin is a sucky company. I am taking that expertise and creating the Michael Scott paper company. I cannot promise success, but I will promise you the best effing time of your life. So anyone who has subscribed to the website got that email. This is so in the vein.
是的。邮件是这样写的：作为邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司的经理，我学到了两件事。关于纸业的一切，以及邓德米夫林是一家烂透了的公司。我将带着这些专业知识，创立迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。我不能保证成功，但我向你保证，这绝对是你一生中最爽的时光。所以任何订阅了网站的人都收到了这封邮件。这简直太符合
I know it's going to come later, but when Jim's like, you know, this is an industry on decline and Michael's like, I practically invented the decline. Like this is the kind of energy he's going into his new business with. Oh, well, listen, that's all I've got for fast facts. A story about Vegas, a little Scotch and Splenda and a surly email from Michael. It's one of my favorite fast facts we've ever done. The Scotch and Splenda might have had something to do with it. Well, why don't we take a break and we'll come back and get into this episode.
我知道这会在后面出现，但当吉姆说，你知道的，这是一个在走下坡路的行业，而迈克尔说，我几乎发明了这个下坡路。就像这是他带着这种能量去开创他的新业务一样。好吧，听着，我的趣味冷知识就到这里。一个关于拉斯维加斯的的故事，一点苏格兰威士忌加代糖，以及来自迈克尔的一封刻薄的邮件。这是我们做过的最喜欢的趣味冷知识之一。苏格兰威士忌加代糖可能跟这有点关系。好吧，我们为什么不休息一下，回来再继续聊这一集呢。
Let's do it. All right, you guys, we are back. Michael is holding court finally in the kitchen. He has everyone's attention. He's telling them the story of how he quit, how he went to New York and quit and told David Wallace, I want you to know this is called the purple cold open. And the Kinsey Chronicles of the office. Why is it called the purple cold open?
我们开始吧。好吧，各位，我们回来了。迈克尔终于在厨房里掌控全场了。他吸引了所有人的注意力。他正在讲他是怎么辞职的，他是怎么去纽约辞职并告诉大卫·华莱士——我想让你们知道，这被称为“紫色片头”。还有办公室的金西纪事。为什么它被称为紫色片头？
I will tell you, Jenna, Angela Martin is wearing a purple turtleneck and a purple cardigan. Pam is wearing a purple top under her cardigan. Kelly is wearing a purple stripe button down shirt. Oscar has purple squares on his tie and sort of faint purple stripes on his shirt. Stanley has purple stripes on his shirt and purple flowers on his tie. And Kevin also has purple stripes. I will have you know, when I saw this cold open, I noted the numerous jewel tones, but I did not break it down like that and I applaud you.
珍娜，我来告诉你，安吉拉·马丁穿着一件紫色高领毛衣和一件紫色开衫。帕姆在开衫里面穿了一件紫色上衣。凯莉穿着一件紫色条纹纽扣衬衫。奥斯卡系着有紫色方格图案的领带，衬衫上有隐隐的紫色条纹。斯坦利衬衫上有紫色条纹，领带上有紫色花朵。凯文也有紫色条纹。我得告诉你们，当我看到这个片头时，我注意到了大量的珠宝色调，但我没有像这样一一细数，我为你鼓掌。
I just was like, what happened? What was Alicia like? Where was her? She was in sort of like a, I don't know, a spring awakening mode of her life. Everyone had purple on in this whole kitchen scene minus Michael. Everyone else had purple on. Just saying. I found it fascinating.
我当时就想，怎么回事？艾丽西亚是怎么样的？她当时处于一种什么状态？她处于她人生的某种，我不知道，可以说是春醒模式。整个厨房里除了迈克尔，每个人都穿了紫色。其他所有人都穿了紫色。我只是随口说说。我觉得这太迷人了。
Now the episode is going to start. Michael is walking around with one of those gooey, stretchy hands, you know, your kids get them at a county fair and then they smack them on the window and that leaves the gooey residue. Michael's walking around, smacking pieces of paper, yanking them back. He messes with Phyllis's hair. I remember Phyllis broke on that. I did too.
现在这一集要开始了。迈克尔拿着一个那种黏糊糊、有弹性的手掌玩具在四处走动，你知道的，你可以在集市上给孩子们买到那种，然后他们把它啪地拍在窗户上，会留下黏糊糊的残留物。迈克尔四处走动，把纸拍在上面，然后猛地拽回来。他弄乱了菲利斯的头发。我记得菲利斯在那一幕笑场了。我也是。
That's why you see her from the back cause she was laughing and I love how he tucked it back in his suit pocket and just the hand like hung down sadly for the rest of the scene. This is also when Michael is drinking his Scotch and Splenda. We reached out to writer Aaron Shore, the writer of this episode, because we were very curious who wrote tastes like Splenda gets you drunk like Scotch. Yeah, we gotta know. I mean, it's just too good. And he said that that line was created in a pre-table draft pitch session.
这就是为什么你看到的是她的背影，因为她在笑，我喜欢他把它塞回西装口袋里的动作，那只手在接下来的场景里就那么无力地垂着。这也是迈克尔在喝他的苏格兰威士忌加代糖的时候。我们联系了本集的编剧亚伦·舒尔，因为我们很好奇是谁写了“喝起来像代糖，醉得像苏格兰威士忌”这句台词。是的，我们得知道。我的意思是，这台词太棒了。他说这句台词是在剧本围读前的提案会议上创作出来的。
So what that means is the writers, they would kind of typically work together to make an outline of each episode and then a specific writer, in this case, Aaron Shore, would go off and write the whole episode based on that outline and they usually got like about a week. Well, they would turn in their draft, they would get notes and then they would also have these pitch sessions. Right. They'll get notes.
所以这意味着编剧们通常会一起合作写出每一集的剧本大纲，然后特定的编剧——在这个案子中是亚伦·舒尔——会根据这个大纲去写整集剧本，他们通常有一周左右的时间。好吧，他们会交出初稿，得到修改意见，然后他们也会有这些提案会议。没错。他们会得到意见。
Sometimes a few of the writers will be put in a pod to pitch on a certain element of the script. Yes. And that is exactly what happened with Scotch and Splenda. A few writers got together and they said, we want a really funny joke for this moment when Michael is walking around with a drink in his hand. And Aaron had saved all of the pitches. Stop it.
有时几个编剧会被分到一个小组，为剧本的某个特定元素提出创意。是的。这正是苏格兰威士忌加代糖的由来。几个编剧聚在一起，他们说，我们想要一个非常搞笑的笑话，用在迈克尔手里拿着一杯饮料四处走动的这个时刻。而亚伦保留了所有的提案。别说了。
Oh my gosh. All of the... Oh my gosh. What were they? Okay. So, Kevin says, is that Scotch? Yeah. And here are the various pitches that Michael would reply.
哦天哪。所有的……哦天哪。都是些什么？好吧，凯文说，那是苏格兰威士忌吗？是的。以下是迈克尔可能回答的各种提案。
Yup, from a fire truck shaped bottle in my office. Or better, southern comfort. Or nope, diet Pepsi and water and ice and Scotch. Or it's non-alcoholic Scotch. And finally, the one they went with, Scotch and Splenda, tastes like Splenda, gets you drunk like Scotch. And then that is the joke that they ultimately picked for our table read draft, which is the draft that all the actors got and that we would read out loud.
是的，来自我办公室里一个消防车形状的瓶子。或者更好的是，南方舒适利口酒。或者不，健怡百事可乐加水、冰块和苏格兰威士忌。或者这是不含酒精的苏格兰威士忌。最后，他们选定的那一句是：苏格兰威士忌加代糖，喝起来像代糖，醉得像苏格兰威士忌。然后这就是他们最终为我们的围读剧本选定的笑话，也就是所有演员拿到并大声朗读的剧本。
I love it. My number two would have been a bottle shaped like a fire truck. I liked bottle shaped like a fire truck as well. Because I remember like my dad had like a novelty liqueur that I think it came in a stagecoach. I don't know. But like it just sat on the shelf. Well, the cool thing about those extra lines was then at the table draft, if it...
我很喜欢。我的第二选择会是一个消防车形状的瓶子。我也喜欢消防车形状的瓶子。因为我记得我爸爸有一个新奇的利口酒瓶，我想它装在一个驿马车里。我不知道。但它就那样放在架子上。好吧，这些多出来的台词的酷炫之处在于，在围读剧本时，如果它……
Oh, Angela is having a sip of Scotch and Splenda. That's the ice that you hear. Because I was like, well, we are talking about Scotch and Splenda. It wasn't a joke, folks. We're really drinking it. Sipping. Sipping it. We're really sipping it.
哦，安吉拉正在喝一口苏格兰威士忌加代糖。你听到的是冰块的声音。因为我想，既然我们在谈论苏格兰威士忌加代糖。伙计们，这不是开玩笑。我们真的在喝。小口啜饮。小口啜饮。我们真的在小口啜饮。
That's your, you are sipping. But what I was going to say is the interesting thing is that those extra jokes, the ones they didn't put in the table draft, they would save in that candy bag document. And then if a joke didn't land at the table read, they might go over there and replace it when it came time for the shooting draft. Sure they would have us do it on set on a different alternate. Right. Sometimes I think the writers just wanted to hear them just for fun.
那是你的，你是在啜饮。但我想说的是，有趣的是，那些额外的笑话，那些没有放进围读剧本里的笑话，会被保存在那个资料袋文档里。然后，如果在围读时某个笑话效果不好，当拍摄剧本定稿时，他们可能会去那里把它替换掉。当然，他们会让我们在片场尝试其他的备选方案。没错。有时我觉得编剧们只是想听听它们，纯粹觉得好玩。
Even though they knew we weren't going to like use any of them, they would hand you a page. And if we had time that day in our shooting schedule, we would just do a whole bunch of alts. And it was always so fun. So fun. Stanley thinks Michael should start looking for another job. Michael says he has a job to which Andy points out for four more days.
尽管他们知道我们不会使用其中的任何一个，但他们会递给你一页纸。如果我们当天的拍摄日程有时间，我们就会做出一堆备选方案。而且总是那么有趣。太有趣了。斯坦利认为迈克尔应该开始找另一份工作了。迈克尔说他有工作，对此安迪指出只剩四天了。
Yeah. Andy's like, you kind of got to get your act together here. Well, Michael has a talking head where he is not worried. I mean, what's he going to do? He's going to do a little bit of this, a little bit of that, and he's going to stop worrying about calories. So during this whole montage of like people giving Michael advice, there was a scene in the shooting draft that didn't make it.
是的。安迪就像是在说，你在这里得把事情理出个头绪来。好吧，迈克尔有一个单人镜头，在镜头里他并不担心。我的意思是，他要做什么？他要这样做一点，那样做一点，他再也不用担心卡路里了。所以在这个关于人们给迈克尔提建议的蒙太奇片段中，拍摄剧本里有一个场景最终没有被剪进正片。
And Kelly walks into his office and she's like, Michael, what are you going to do? You know what I would do? I'd move to Mexico. I'd live on the beach. I'd be naked. I'd make jewelry, have amazing sex, drink lots of margaritas. She just kind of goes off on this whole thing. And while Kelly is rambling on and on about what she would do, he is carving into his
凯莉走进他的办公室说，迈克尔，你打算怎么办？你知道我会怎么做吗？我会搬去墨西哥。我会住在海滩上。我会一丝不挂。我会做首饰，拥有美妙的性爱，喝大量的玛格丽特酒。她就这样滔滔不绝地说了一大堆。正当凯莉喋喋不休地谈论她会做什么时，他在自己的
desk. Michael was here. Oh my God. And he really carved into the top of the desk. I was like, did we trash a desk for this like scene that never even made it in? And I wasn't the only one that noticed. Olivia C wrote in and said, in the deleted scenes, they're on the DVD box set, guys. We see that Michael has carved Michael was here on the desk.
桌子上刻字。迈克尔到此一游。哦，天哪。他真的在桌子面上刻了字。我当时想，为了这个甚至没被剪进正片的场景，我们把一张桌子给毁了吗？而且不仅我一个人注意到了这一点。奥利维娅·C写信说，在DVD套装的删除片段里，伙计们，我们看到迈克尔在桌子上刻下了“迈克尔到此一游”。
Did Steve really carve that into the desk? Olivia, I had the same question, but guess what? Randy Cordray had the answer. He said our production designer, Michael Gallenberg, created a matching desktop out of the exact same similar wood. Wow. I know that was laminated over the actual desktop because we were shooting scenes out of order and they couldn't have different stages of Michael carving into his desk in
史蒂夫真的把那个刻在桌子上了吗？奥利维娅，我也有同样的疑问，但你猜怎么着？兰迪·科德雷有答案。他说我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦贝格用完全相同相似的木头制作了一个配套的桌面。哇。我知道那是贴在真实桌面上的压层板，因为我们是跨场次拍摄的，他们不能在剧集中展示迈克尔在桌子上刻字的各个不同阶段，
the episode because then it wouldn't match. So they just had this laminate top they would put on top and then they would take it away. Now let me ask you this question. That means that Vada, our script supervisor, would have had a chart and on that chart for each scene, it would say carve desk, no carve desk. She would have tracked when we should see the carving. But they didn't know they were going to cut this scene until later. So is it possible that we can see this carving on his desk throughout the episode?
否则就接不上了。所以他们只是制作了这样一个压层板放在顶部，拍完后就拿走。现在我问你这个问题。这意味着我们的场记瓦达会有一张表格，在每场戏的表格上都会写着：刻桌子，不刻桌子。她会追踪我们什么时候应该看到这个刻痕。但他们直到后来才知道要剪掉这场戏。所以我们有没有可能在这集的整个过程中都在他的桌子上看到这个刻痕呢？
Maybe. You'd have to be close, right? Like over his shoulder. Yeah. But I mean, probably what a headache for Vada. It's like keeping track of all that. And then it didn't even make it in. I'll have you know, Angela, at two minutes, 48 seconds, we had a fan catch from Flora
也许吧。你得凑得很近，对吧？就像从他肩膀后面看过去。是的。但我的意思是，对瓦达来说这得是多大的头疼事啊。就像追踪所有这些一样。结果它甚至都没被剪进去。安吉拉，我得告诉你，在2分48秒时，我们有一个粉丝捕捉到了彩蛋，来自弗洛拉·
Kay. There is a blooming plant at reception. Flora! Good catch. I knew it would make your heart happy. I saw it too, Flora. You know, the last time we had a blooming plant at reception was beach games. So you think this is connected to Pam?
凯。前台那里有一株开花的植物。弗洛拉！好眼光。我知道这会让你的心感到温暖。我也看到了，弗洛拉。你知道，我们上一次在前台看到开花的植物还是在《海滩游戏》那一集。所以你认为这跟帕姆有关吗？
Pam is going to have her moment here. She's going to have another moment. She's going to bloom again today, like in beach games. Now I know we talked to Steve Dusharer, who told us that it was a coincidence, that it was a blooming plant for beach games, but Steve, Dusharer, again, with the blooming plant, Pam is blooming. I think it was subconscious. This is that group mind thing.
帕姆在这里要有高光时刻了。她会有另一个高光时刻。她今天要再次绽放了，就像在《海滩游戏》里那样。现在我知道我们跟史蒂夫·杜沙勒谈过，他告诉我们这只是个巧合，那盆开花的植物是为了《海滩游戏》，但是史蒂夫·杜沙勒，又来一盆开花的植物，帕姆正在绽放。我认为这是潜意识的。这就是那种集体思维。
That's what I was going to say. This is creative group mind. Well, Michael is now going to move into the kitchen. I guess he's hungry. So he's looking for some food. He's a little tipsy and he's going to go like raid the refrigerator. Who hasn't been there? Come on.
我正要这么说。这就是创造性的集体思维。好吧，迈克尔现在要搬到厨房里去了。我想他饿了。所以他在找点吃的。他有点微醺，打算去洗劫冰箱。谁没经历过那种时候呢？拜托。
In the script, it just said that Michael takes out a container clearly labeled Phyllis. But you know how he's eating it and then he's like, Phyllis, none of that was in the script. Oh, really? Nope. Steve just improvised that. Oh, that's so good. Andy comes in and he wants to give Michael some wine as a farewell gift.
剧本里只是写着迈克尔拿出一个明显贴着菲利斯标签的容器。但你知道他是怎么一边吃一边说，菲利斯，这些都不是剧本里的。哦，真的吗？没有。这完全是史蒂夫即兴发挥的。哦，太棒了。安迪进来了，他想送给迈克尔一些酒作为告别礼物。
It's actually a really nice gesture. It is. And Michael just doesn't give a crap. Michael would love it if Jim came in and gave him a bottle of wine. I know. But, you know, it's Andy. So he's like, I already have wine. This next scene I loved because Michael is sitting on the couch by front reception and
这其实是一个非常友好的举动。确实是。而迈克尔根本不在乎。如果吉姆进来送他一瓶酒，迈克尔会很乐意的。我知道。但是，你知道的，那是安迪。所以他就说，我已经有酒了。接下来这场戏我非常喜欢，因为迈克尔正坐在前台旁边的沙发上，
a man walks in. He's interviewing for Michael's job. Yeah. Michael is kind of on the couch reading a novel. I zoomed in on it. I tried to see what it was. It's like a woman in a martini glass. It's clearly like a sort of…
一个男人走了进来。他来面试迈克尔的工作。是的。迈克尔正坐在沙发上读一本小说。我放大了画面。我试图看清那是什么。那是一个女人坐在马提尼酒杯里。这显然是一种……
A romance novel? No. It seems like one of those like books for women about, you know, claim your space sort of book. Yeah. Yeah. Like a motivational… Yes.
言情小说？不。这看起来像是那种写给女性的书，关于，你知道的，宣示你的空间的某种书。是的。是的。就像一本励志……是的。
That's what it looked like to me. So a couple of things. At four minutes, 16 seconds, the blooming plant is on the move. It's been moved to the other side of the reception desk. So you can see the couch better. Yeah. The man who's interviewing for the job is named Mr. Isaac Sylvie. And Aaron Schur told us that he was named after Aaron's kids, Isaac and Sylvie.
这正是我所看到的。所以有几件事。在4分16秒时，那盆开花的植物移动了位置。它被搬到了前台桌子的另一边。这样你就能更好地看清沙发了。是的。来面试这个工作的这个人名叫艾萨克·西尔维先生。亚伦·舒尔告诉我们，这个名字是以亚伦的孩子艾萨克和西尔维的名字命名的。
Isn't that so cute? Yes. He had originally named the character Mr. Engbritzen. But Paul Lieberstein told him, no, name him after your kids. So that's how he got the name Mr. Isaac Sylvie. He was played by David Grant Wright, who has appeared in several episodes of Better Call Saul, Crazy Ex-Girlfriend, and Brooklyn Nine-Nine, and pretty much every soap opera you can imagine.
这不是很可爱吗？是的。他原本给这个角色起名叫恩格里岑先生。但保罗·利伯斯坦告诉他，不，用你孩子名字命名。这就是他叫艾萨克·西尔维先生的由来。他由大卫·格兰特·怀特饰演，他曾在《风骚律师》、《疯狂前女友》和《神烦警探》等多集电视剧中出演，几乎出演了你能想象到的每一部肥皂剧。
David is an incredible actor, and I read his bio. He is a 27-year cancer survivor. Oh, wow. He wrote a one-man show called With Flying Colors about his cancer experience, which he has performed for the last 25 years, raising thousands of dollars for cancer patients. Good human alert. Yes. Good human alert.
大卫是一位不可思议的演员，我读过他的简历。他是癌症康复27年的幸存者。哦，天哪。他写了一部名为《凯旋而归》的独角兽戏剧，讲述了他患癌的经历，并在过去的25年里一直表演这部剧，为癌症患者筹集了数千美元。好人警报。是的。好人警报。
That's fantastic. Well, in this scene, Michael finds out that Isaac has driven all the way from Philly. And Michael's like, gosh, that's a heck of a drive. And Isaac said, yeah, well, this is one of the few places hiring. It's rough out there. When you sort of see the realization coming over Michael's face, Jenna, there was more to the scene. It was so good.
太棒了。好吧，在这场戏里，迈克尔发现艾萨克是一路从费城开车过来的。迈克尔就说，天哪，这开车可够远的。艾萨克说，是啊，好吧，这是少数几个还在招聘的地方之一。外面太难混了。当你看到这种顿悟浮现在迈克尔脸上时，珍娜，这场戏还有更多内容。太精彩了。
I read it in the shooting draft. He has his resume out, Isaac, and Michael's like, can I see that? Michael is so blown away. He finds out that Isaac was the president of the company he used to work at. Wow. Yeah. And now he's driving all the way from Philly for a regional manager position. Michael is so blown away by his resume, he says, can I keep this?
我在拍摄剧本里读到了。他拿出了简历，艾萨克，迈克尔就说，我能看看吗？迈克尔惊呆了。他发现艾萨克曾是他以前工作过的那家公司的总裁。哇。是的。现在他为了一个地区经理的职位，大老远从费城开车过来。迈克尔对他的简历惊叹不已，他说，我能留着这个吗？
And then he really starts to spiral. And he goes to see Toby and asks Toby for resume advice, like how to beef up his resume. This made it into the deleted scenes. It's so good. Can we hear it? Hey, Toby, I have a real quick question for you. It's about a resume. Sure.
然后他真的开始情绪失控了。他去找托比，向托比征求关于简历的建议，比如如何丰富自己的简历。这段被剪进了删除片段里。太精彩了。我们能听听吗？嘿，托比，我有个很小的问题想问你。关于简历的。当然。
So we might start with, so your most recent thing, you know, summary of achievements. What have you done here at Dunder Mifflin? Regional manager, Dick Watt. Okay. So, you know, how would you actually describe what you did? Change things. Ushered in a new era of love and comedy in the workplace. Hired many, fired none, made money, lost money, learned to stop counting.
所以我们可以从……比如你最近的经历，成就总结。你在邓德米夫林都做过什么？地区经理，干得挺烂。好吧。所以，你知道，你实际上会怎么描述你做过的事？改变事物。引领了职场爱与喜剧的新时代。雇用了许多人，解雇了零人，赚了钱，亏了钱，学会了不再计较。
This is our moment. This is our time. This next part should be sung if possible. That made me laugh so hard. The scene continued. Toby said, how would you describe what you did? And Michael has this speech and it didn't make it in. This is Michael talking about himself.
这是我们的时刻。这是我们的时代。如果可能的话，这下一部分应该唱出来。这把我逗得笑得前仰后合。这场戏还在继续。托比说，你会怎么描述你做过的事？然后迈克尔发表了一段演讲，但没有被剪进正片。这是迈克尔在谈论他自己。
Michael Scott always had a strange recipe for success, two cups of spirit, a half a thing of inspiration, two spoonfuls of love, a water bottle of danger, a pinch of praise, a dash of hopes, a sprinkle of cinnamon, two pats of butter, a box of cake mix, and a little bit of cooking oil, preheat oven. Wait. What am I describing? It made me laugh so hard. That's his description of what he did.
迈克尔·斯科特总是有一套奇怪的成功秘方：两杯精神，半份灵感，两勺爱，一水瓶的危险，一撮赞美，一小撮希望，少许肉桂，两小块黄油，一盒蛋糕预拌粉，还有一点食用油，预热烤箱。等等。我到底在描述什么？这把我逗得笑得前仰后合。这就是他对所做之事的描述。
Okay. That talking head is very funny, but I have to say what I think I can tell you. It's the biggest scotch because it's so funny to me. Is it not that funny? No, but I've shared a drink with you before, Angela, and you're getting into that. I'm tickled. You're getting into that, yes, that territory where you giggle. I haven't even had a full scotch and splitter.
好吧，那个单人镜头非常搞笑，但我不得不说我认为我能告诉你的是。这是最大的一杯苏格兰威士忌，因为这对我来说太搞笑了。难道不是那么搞笑吗？不，但我以前和你分享过一杯饮品，安吉拉，你现在正进入那种状态。我很开心。你进入了那个状态，是的，那个会让你咯咯笑的领域。我甚至还没喝完一杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖。
No, no, you haven't. And I just have to say one more time. It's so good. It's really good. I know. All right. All right. Let's move on.
不，不，你没有。我不得不再次强调。这太棒了。真的很好。我知道。好吧。好吧。我们继续吧。
Yes, let's. We need to talk about this new copier. I guess we have this whole runner about copier or chairs. We never saw them get their chairs, but they have gotten a new copier now. I did love that for the whole beginning of the episode, it was wrapped in the blue sort of packaging and no one said anything about it. I just love how things are in the backdrop like that. I do too.
好的，我们继续。我们需要谈谈这个新复印机。我想我们有关于复印机或椅子的整条副线。我们从来没看到他们拿到椅子，但他们现在有了一台新复印机。我很喜欢这一集刚开始时，它被包裹在蓝色的包装膜里，却没有人对它说什么。我就是喜欢这种作为背景存在的细节。我也是。
Pam has a talking head where she says that they delivered this new copier, but they didn't set it up. So Pam's job today is setting up this copier. This would do me in. Yeah. I wouldn't be able to do it. I don't like reading instructions. I don't like manuals.
帕姆有一个单人镜头，她说他们送来了这台新复印机，但没有安装。所以帕姆今天的工作就是安装这台复印机。这绝对会把我折腾死。是的。我肯定搞不定。我不喜欢读说明书。我不喜欢手册。
When I get any kind of appliance and it comes with the manual, I just stash the manual in a corner. This is reminding me of the document that we got when it was time to do the layout edit of our book. You guys, it was like building a small Cessna. Are we allowed to take a picture of that and put it on the pod? Because to me, it looked like some sort of scientific formula. It was all of these instructions for how to make a comment on the PDF.
当我买任何电器并且它附带说明书时，我只会把说明书塞在角落里。这让我想起了我们做书的排版编辑时收到的那个文件。伙ites，那感觉就像是在组装一架小型赛斯纳飞机。我们能把那张照片拍下来发到播客上吗？因为在我看来，它看起来就像某种科学公式。那是关于如何在PDF上做批注的所有这些说明。
And when I looked at it, my brain exploded and you got on the phone with me and said, I can't do it. I can't do it. Lady, I can't do it. I will mess it up. So we got on the phone together and every time you had a note, I read the document and I carefully made the note on the PDF. So if you buy our book, OfficeBFFs, just know that we now know how to, well, Jenna knows
当我看到它时，我的大脑直接爆炸了，你给我打电话说，我做不到。我做不到。姑娘，我做不到。我会把它弄砸的。所以我们一起通了电话，每次你有批注时，我都读了那份文件，并在PDF上小心翼翼地做了批注。所以如果你买我们的书《办公室闺蜜》，只要知道我们现在知道怎么……好吧，珍娜知道
how to do a note on an elaborate layout craziness document and I learned how to build a Cessna airplane. Yeah. But we cared and we put that love and care into our book. I'm buzzed. I know. While Pam is going to be putting this copier together, Kevin is constantly bugging her and there's a lot of Pam sass here.
如何在复杂的排版疯狂文档中做批注，而我学会了如何建造一架赛斯纳飞机。是的。但我们在乎，我们把这种爱和用心倾注到了我们的书里。我有点微醺了。我知道。正当帕姆在组装这台复印机时，凯文一直在烦她，这里有很多帕姆的辣妹式吐槽。
I loved shooting this scene with Brian. We shot it first thing in the morning. They would do this when there were scenes at reception in particular that didn't feature the rest of the office. That meant nobody had to be in the background and you guys didn't have to come in so early. So Brian and I came in first thing. It was probably 6.37 in the morning when we shot this scene, but I loved it. We had so much fun and I got to sass him.
我很喜欢和布莱恩一起拍这场戏。我们一大早就拍了。当有前台的场景且不需要办公室其他人出镜时，他们通常会这么做。这意味着不需要任何人当背景，你们也不用那么早来。所以我和布莱恩一大早就来了。拍这场戏时大概是早上6点37分，但我很喜欢。我们玩得很开心，我也能狠狠地吐槽他。
I think that we learn that in the accounting department, Kevin is tasked with all the menial tasks. Like, go make photocopies. Go do this. You're so right. That's why he cares so much about the copier. It's his one job. When Pam talks about how a copier goes through a lot, I loved the runner of things that happen
我想我们了解到，在会计部门，凯文负责所有的杂务。比如，去复印。去做这个。你太对了。这就是为什么他这么关心这台复印机。这是他唯一的活儿。当帕姆谈到复印机要经历多少折腾时，我很喜欢发生在
to this copier. Oh, yes. We didn't talk about that. It's so great. First of all, Creed puts coins into it. Right there. Creed is probably messed with all the mechanisms and Oscar's like, I think it's 75 cents. So he keeps feeding coins into it and then, of course, band it, choose on the wires and
这台复印机身上的系列事件。哦，是的。我们没聊过这个。太棒了。首先，克里德往里面塞硬币。就在那儿。克里德可能把所有的内部机制都弄乱了，而奥斯卡说，我觉得是75美分。所以他一直往里投硬币，然后，当然了，班迪特还在啃咬电线，
then Kevin dumps a whole cup of coffee over the entire copier. It's no wonder this thing doesn't work. I know. I had a question for Randy Cordray at five minutes, 12 seconds. When we see Bandit chewing on the copier cord, I was like, Randy, do we know who the cat actor was because you have this whole list of the cat actors? It looked like Bandit. Well, Bandit was played in this scene by the ever reliable milkman.
接着凯文把整整一杯咖啡倒在了整个复印机上。难怪这东西不工作了。我知道。在5分12秒时，我有一个问题想问兰迪·科德雷。当我们看到班迪特在啃复印机电线时，我在想，兰迪，我们知道猫演员是谁吗，因为你有一整份猫演员的名单？这看起来像班迪特。嗯，班迪特这场戏是由那只极其靠谱的送奶工猫饰演的。
Oh, milkman. Oh, milkman. Randy said it took several days of training to get milkman to actually chew on the cord, which was painted with sardine oil. Oh, wow. The training of the cat, the labor, the transportation cost, the cat rental for this episode, for this very simple three-second insert shot cost us, any guesses anyone? Three seconds, a cat licking a cord.
哦，送奶工。哦，送奶工。兰迪说，为了让送奶工真正去啃那根涂了沙丁鱼油的电线，他们花了几天时间进行训练。哦，天哪。训练这只猫、人工成本、交通费用、这一集里这只猫的出场费，对于这个非常简单的三秒钟插入镜头，大家猜猜花了多少钱？三秒钟，一只猫舔电线。
Any guesses? Cassie? She guessed $2,000. Sam? I'm going to go big and say $10,000. I'll hit it in the middle at seven. $1,710. Oh.
大家有什么猜测吗？卡西？她猜2000美元。萨姆？我猜个大的，1万美元。我折中一下，说7000。1710美元。哦。
Cassie gets it. Cassie wins. Close us without going over. And once again, we use Bob Dunn's Animal Rentals from Somar, California with Denise Sanders, our lead cat trainer. Once again, a simple little three-second joke took somebody a week to make happen. We are going to go to Jim's desk and over his shoulder, we can hear monster sounds coming from Michael's office.
卡西猜中了。卡西赢了。在不超过预算的情况下最接近。我们再次使用了位于加利福尼亚州索马里的鲍勃·邓恩动物租赁公司，由我们的首席猫类训练师丹尼斯·桑德斯负责。又一次，一个简单的小三秒笑话花了一个星期才得以实现。我们要去吉姆的桌子那儿，越过他的肩膀，我们能听到迈克尔办公室里传来的怪兽声音。
And I love this line when Jim says, it's monster.com singular. He knew. He knew. We actually got a lot of mail about this bit. OK. People wondered, where did we get the monster sounds? Well, as it turns out, it was none other than our post-production supervisor's voice, Jake Oust, making monster sounds.
我非常喜欢吉姆说的这句台词：是怪物网站（Monster.com），单数。他心知肚明。他心知肚明。我们其实收到了很多关于这个包袱的邮件。好吧。人们很好奇，我们是从哪里弄来的怪兽声音？嗯，事实证明，这正是我们的后期制作主管杰克·奥斯特的声音，他在模仿怪兽叫声。
Get out. Yes, Jake. I guess he just recorded monster sounds into a microphone, and then our sound supervisor, Bobby Maxden, took the recording, added some reverb and some scary special effects, and that is how we got our fakeymonsters.com website. Jake, really good job with the monsters. I agree. This leads us into a Michael talking head, where he says, if you work in paper long enough,
别开玩笑了。是的，杰克。我猜他只是把怪兽的声音录进麦克风里，然后我们的声音主管鲍比·马克登拿到了录音，添加了一些混响和一些可怕的特效，这就是我们如何得到那个假的怪兽网站。杰克，怪兽声音模仿得真不错。我同意。这把我们带入了迈克尔的一个单人镜头，在镜头里他说，如果你在纸业工作的时间够长，
you get to know the players, and he's going to start calling some paper companies to maybe get a job. Well, we find out there's only one on his list. Are you ready for the saddest outgoing message ever? Yeah. Here it is. Hi. You've reached Prince Paper.
你就会了解业内的大佬，他要开始给一些纸业公司打电话看能不能找份工作。嗯，我们发现他的名单上只有一个。你准备好迎接史上最悲伤的离职留言了吗？是的。就是这个。你好。你已拨通普林斯纸业。
We are sad to inform you that after 40 years of serving the community, we are no longer in business. Thank you for your support, and may God bless you. Bye. Yeah. Oh, that was harsh. That was Prince Family Paper, the small family-owned paper business that Michael and Dwight have clearly put out of business.
我们很遗憾地通知您，在服务社区40年之后，我们已不再营业。感谢您的支持，愿上帝保佑您。再见。是的。哦，太残酷了。那是普林斯家族纸业，那家迈克尔和德怀特显然给挤兑倒闭的小型家族纸业公司。
The little girl at the end. Bye. I'll have you know, they were uncredited, but we brought back the original cast members of the Prince Family to do the voices. That is Dan Desmond as Roger Prince and Emily Ray Argenti as his granddaughter Rebecca Prince. When I heard that again, I mean, I knew it was coming, right? I knew it was coming, but still, I was like, in his voice waivers, I was like, oh, I know. Well, Michael needs to now figure something out.
最后那个小女孩。再见。我得告诉你们，虽然他们没有署名，但我们请回了普林斯家族的原班演员来配音。那是丹·德斯蒙德饰演罗杰·普林斯，还有艾米莉·雷·阿根蒂饰演他的孙女丽贝卡·普林斯。当我再次听到这个时，我的意思是，我知道它要来了，对吧？我知道它要来，但即便如此，当他的声音颤抖时，我还是在想，哦，我懂的。好吧，迈克尔现在得想个办法了。
So at 16 minutes, 49 seconds, he's going to start throwing stuff at Jim to get his attention so that Jim will come in his office. Yeah. He's going to call Jim, but instead he's going to throw a kush ball at him. Well, Jim goes in his office and Michael's like, close your eyes, because I'm going to tell you something. And Jim will not close his eyes. And this is when Michael reveals he's going to start his own paper company, leading to
所以在16分49秒时，他开始向吉姆扔东西来吸引吉姆的注意力，这样吉姆就会去他的办公室。是的。他要叫吉姆，但取而代之的是向他扔了一个库什球。好吧，吉姆走进了他的办公室，迈克尔说，闭上眼睛，因为我要告诉你一件事。而吉姆就是不闭上眼睛。这就是迈克尔透露他要创办自己的纸业公司的时候，这引出了
your favorite couplet that we talked about earlier. Yeah. Do you know how the industry is in decline? Do I? I practically invented decline. He goes on to tell Jim he has a name for the company and he wants Jim maybe to be a part of it. He's very excited.
我们之前讨论过的你最喜欢的对白。是的。你知道这个行业现在是在走下坡路吗？我吗？我几乎就是下坡路的发明者。他接着告诉吉姆他已经给公司想好了一个名字，并且他希望吉姆也能成为其中一部分。他非常兴奋。
It's a big no from Jim. I'll have you know, at six minutes, 44 seconds, I spotted something. What? The desk? No. Oh. Do you remember in season three, the job part one, I noticed that the outlet in Michael's office, the one under the big photo on his sidewall, was upside down.
吉姆直接拒绝了。我得告诉你，在6分44秒时，我发现了一个细节。什么？那张桌子？不。哦。你还记得在第三季的《工作（上）》中，我注意到迈克尔办公室里的那个插座，就是他侧墙大照片底下的那个，是倒着装的吗？
Correct. And in that podcast, we learned that you can install outlets any way you want and they still work. You can put them sideways, you can put them up and down. I also said in that episode that I would be tracking outlets. I'll have you know. You didn't forget. I didn't forget.
没错。在那个播客中，我们了解到你可以随心所欲地安装插座，它们依然能用。你可以把它们横着装，也可以竖着装。我在那一集中还说过，我会追踪插座的使用情况。我要告诉你。你没忘。我没忘。
And if you look at that outlet, it is now facing up. It is facing the correct way. Ta-da! I kept my word. Well, you did. And the outlet is now up and down. There you go. Outlet tracker, Jenna Fisher.
如果你看看那个插座，它现在是朝上的。它朝向了正确的方向。嗒哒！我言出必行。嗯，你确实做到了。而且这个插座现在是上下方向的。你看。插座追踪者，珍娜·费舍尔。
Mission accomplished. Charles is going to interrupt. Jenna is taking a drink of her Scotch and Splendid. I've been drinking water. Busted. What? Yeah, I just saw you drink. Charles is going to come in and once again, Jim is in the wrong place at the wrong time
大功告成。查尔斯要来打断了。珍娜正在喝苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我一直在喝水。抓个正着。什么？对，我刚才看见你喝了。查尔斯要进来了，又一次，吉姆在错误的时间出现在了错误的地方
and he breaks up their meeting. Yeah, because he says, Michael has given his two weeks notice. Jim, did you also give your two weeks notice? And Jim's like, nope, nope, I'm going to go have a seat. We just need to find a way to get to drink. So I literally just said, I just want to say something. We need to, I was going to say, we need to find a way to get to break. But you said to get to drink.
然后他打断了他们的会议。对，因为他说，迈克尔已经提交了两周的离职通知。吉姆，你也提交了两周的离职通知吗？吉姆说，不，不，我去那边坐着。我们只是需要找个方法去喝一杯。所以我刚才 literalmente 说了，我只是想说点什么。我们需要，我本来想说，我们需要找个方法去休息。但你说的是去喝一杯。
That's what I said. We need to find a way to get to drink. You guys, I want you to know it is 1048 AM. Maybe we should go to break and drink some water. I think we should go to break and drink some water. We'll be right back. Okay, we are back. We have hydrated ourselves.
我是这么说的。我们需要找个方法去喝一杯。各位，我想让你们知道现在是上午10点48分。也许我们应该去休息一下，喝点水。我觉得我们应该去休息一下，喝点水。我们马上回来。好的，我们回来了。我们已经补充水分了。
Angela's eating some cheese. Mm-hmm. Jenna drank some water. We're going to be very serious podcasters now. We're serious. Don't worry. By the way, I wanted to start before we jump back into the episode, I just want to give a big plug to BJ Novak's new show on Hulu called The Premise.
安吉拉在吃奶酪。嗯哼。珍娜喝了点水。我们现在要成为非常严肃的播客主播了。我们很严肃。别担心。顺便说一句，在我们跳回这一集之前，我想先大力推荐一下BJ·诺瓦克在Hulu上的新剧《上流社会》。
It is so good. I've seen every episode, BJ, you are killing it. Every episode is standalone. It's like an anthology show with a different cast. He's directed many of them. He's written them. You know what I didn't expect. So I just saw the first one.
它太棒了。我看过每一集，BJ，你太厉害了。每一集都是独立的。它就像一部选集剧，演员阵容各异。许多集都是他导演的。都是他写的。你知道我没想到什么吗。我刚刚看了第一集。
BJ starts it. Yes, he has an introduction moment. Yeah, and I was like, oh my god, BJ, I didn't expect to see you. Well, they're great. BJ is one of the smartest people I know, him and Mindy are just- Two of the smartest people in the room. Yes, always. And he has this way of articulating complex thoughts in a really relatable way.
BJ开场。是的，他有一个引子镜头。是的，当时我就想，哦天哪，BJ，我没想到能见到你。它们真的很棒。BJ是我认识的最聪明的人之一，他和明迪简直是——房间里最聪明的两个人。是的，总是这样。他有一种能以真正接地气的方式阐述复杂想法的能力。
And brilliantly funny way. Yeah. Relatable way. And brilliantly funny way. Yeah. He's the guy who wrote Diversity Day. That's all you need to know. He's also the guy that wrote the book with no pictures.
而且方式极其搞笑。对。接地气的方式。而且方式极其搞笑。对。他就是写了《多元化日》的那个人。这就够了。他也是写了《没有图画的书》的那个人。
It's one of our kids' favorite books, and we've read it to them over and over over the years. The sort of scope of BJ's brilliance is really amazing. Yeah. BJ, we love you. We love you. We love your show. Check it out, The Premise on Hulu.
这是我们孩子们最喜欢的书之一，这些年来我们一遍又一遍地读给他们听。BJ才华的广度真的很惊人。是的，BJ，我们爱你。我们爱你。我们爱你的节目。去看看吧，Hulu上的《上流社会》。
And if you have a young and the book with no pictures, you will love it. Back to the episode, Pam is on the ground with this copier manual. And Dwight comes over. This is a really cool shot. This was directed by Paul Lieberstein. This was his idea to put the camera on the floor with Pam. I thought it was a really great idea. You know, at a certain point, there's only so many ways to shoot this documentary.
如果你有小孩子，又读过《没有图画的书》，你一定会喜欢它。回到这一集，帕姆正拿着复印机手册趴在地上。德怀特走了过来。这是一个非常酷的镜头。这是由保罗·利伯斯坦导演的。把摄像机和帕姆一起放在地板上是他的主意。我觉得这是个非常棒的主意。你知道，在某种程度上，拍摄这部纪录片的方法也就只有那么多。
And he found a new one. I think Paul liked to have some of the artsy shots, because do you remember when Jan goes to comfort Michael, and he's sitting in the train, like you just saw the faraway shot of his feet? Yeah. So I think Paul likes those interesting shots. In the next scene, Michael goes up to Pam, kind of sneaky. He wants her to help him make a order form for his new company, which is basically Dunder
而他找到了一种新方法。我觉得保罗喜欢一些具有艺术感的镜头，因为你还记得简去安慰迈克尔的那场戏吗，他坐在火车上，就像你刚刚看到他脚部的远景镜头？是的。所以我觉得保罗喜欢那些有趣的镜头。在下一场戏中，迈克尔鬼鬼祟祟地走到帕姆身边。他想让她帮他为他的新公司制作一份订单，这基本上就是邓德
Mifflin's order form, but with Michael Scott Paper Company in the corner in place of Dunder Mifflin. Right. She's like, okay. All right. Let me think about this. And she comes up with this way that they could kind of do this, scan it. And he says, I was thinking maybe we would just tape it, put a little piece of paper
米夫林的订单，只是在角落里用“迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司”代替了“邓德米夫林”。没错。她说，好吧。好吧。让我想想。然后她想出了一个他们可以这样做的办法，扫描一下。他说，我在想也许我们可以直接用胶带贴一下，拿一小张纸
over it, tape it. She's like, okay. I feel like this is the moment that starts Pam's storyline of feeling very easily replaceable, because she's been studying and studying this manual and thinks she's kind of had this great idea about how to use this new information, and it's just like that replaced. With some tape. At eight minutes and 41 seconds, I want you to know on Pam's desk, Nick is still in the office all day.
盖在上面，用胶带贴上。她说，好吧。我觉得这就是帕姆开始觉得自己非常容易被替代的剧情线的时刻，因为她一直在废寝忘食地研究这本手册，以为自己对如何利用这些新信息有个绝妙的主意，结果就这样被替代了。用一张胶带。在8分41秒时，我想让你们知道在帕姆的桌子上，尼克整天都还在办公室里。
Well, the post-it is still there. Nick has been in the office for three episodes now. Nick in office. Nick in office. All right. Now we're going to get into this really wonderful scene in the conference room. The Angela Kelly rivalry is going strong. Kelly is talking to Charles about how she has to leave early on Tuesdays to pick up
好吧，便签还在那儿。尼克在办公室已经呆了三集了。尼克在办公室。尼克在办公室。好了。现在我们要进入会议室里这个非常精彩的场景了。安吉拉和凯利的竞争愈演愈烈。凯利正在对查尔斯说，她周二必须早退去接
her little sisters from school, because, you know, they're kind of like the Kardashians. Angela's going to come in because she wants to show Charles that brochure for the accounting seminar she was telling him about. Yeah. The brochure, he has a degree in accounting. Charles is like, did Michael just allow anyone in his office at any time? Okay. So this was in the script.
她的妹妹们放学，因为，你知道的，她们有点像卡戴珊家族。安吉拉走进来，因为她想向查尔斯展示她向他提过的那个会计研讨会的宣传册。是的，宣传册，他可是有会计学位的。查尔斯就像是在说，迈克尔以前允许任何人随时进入他的办公室吗？好吧。所以这在剧本里是有的。
I looked it up to see how much was AdLib and wasn't. And there was a prompt for Angela and Kelly to talk at the same time. And we did add a little bit more, but basically we both just were going to gush like, oh, yeah, he was like, come on in. I felt like this was super animated Angela. Well, you know, she is turning on the charm for Mr. Charles Minor. I know. She said there was a Sunday bar at the accounting seminar, but she didn't eat any, you know,
我查了一下，看看有多少是即兴发挥的，有多少不是。剧本里确实有提示让安吉拉和凯利同时说话。我们确实加了一点点，但基本上我们俩都打算滔滔不绝地说，哦，对，他以前总是说，请进。我觉得这是一个超级活泼的安吉拉。好吧，你知道的，她正在向查尔斯·迈纳先生大放魅力。我知道。她说会计研讨会上有一个周日酒吧，但她什么也没吃，你知道的，
just a trim. And then Kelly shoes her out and turns to Charles and says, yeah, she's really special. You know, she's turning 50 this year. I was actually 37 when we filmed this. I am 50 now. You know, when we were trading messages with Aaron Shore, he wrote us about a prank that Idris Elba played on the writers before he came to set. Yeah.
只是稍微节食了一下。然后凯利把她轰了出去，转向查尔斯说，是啊，她真的很特别。你知道，她今年要过50岁生日了。我们拍这场戏的时候我其实37岁。我现在50岁了。你知道的，当我们和亚伦·舒尔发信息时，他给我们写了一个关于伊드里斯·艾尔巴在来片场前对编剧们恶作剧的故事。是的。
Now he actually said, I don't know if this was a prank that Mindy played on us pretending that it was from Idris or if it was actually from Idris. But I guess they got this email that was like, listen, Idris gets really upset if you mispronounce his name and his name is pronounced Idris Elba. It's so ridiculous. And they wrote it out. Idris Elba. Yeah, they sounded it out.
现在他其实说过，我不知道这到底是明迪假装是伊德里斯发给我们的恶作剧，还是真的是伊德里斯发来的。但我想他们收到了一封电子邮件，大意是：听着，如果你们把他的名字读错，伊德里斯会非常生气，他的名字读作“Idris Elba”。太荒谬了。他们还把发音写了出来。Idris Elba。是的，他们把音标标出来了。
But then a bunch of them were like, I swear, that's not right. And so for the first week that Idris was on the show, all of the writers were afraid to call him by his name. And then they found out that this was not true at all. Number one, that his name is Idris and number two, that he doesn't get mad if you mispronounce his name. But I thought that was really funny. Idris, was that you or was it Mindy?
但接着他们中的许多人觉得，我发誓，那不对。所以在伊德里斯来到剧组的第一周里，所有的编剧都不敢直呼他的名字。然后他们发现这完全不是真的。第一，他的名字叫伊德里斯；第二，如果你读错了他的名字，他根本不会生气。但我觉得这真的很有趣。伊德里斯，那是你干的还是明迪干的？
By the way, Idris, we have tried to reach out to you. We don't know how to get ahold of you. We'd love for you to be on the show. We did find some of your peeps, but they said you're busy. Very busy, I guess. You're super busy. You're making two movies and you're promoting another movie. You're busy.
顺便说一句，伊德里斯，我们曾试图联系你。我们不知道怎么联系你。我们很希望你能来节目。我们确实找到了你的几个手下，但他们说你很忙。我想是非常忙。你超级忙。你正在拍两部电影，还在宣传另一部电影。你很忙。
We're here for you, Idris. Idris, anytime. Anytime. If you would like a Scotch and Splenda. We're your gals. With two gals who loved at Google. We're here for you. Well, Charles has a talking head where he just kind of owns it.
我们一直在为你守候，伊德里斯。伊德里斯，随时都可以。随时都可以。如果你想来杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我们就是你的女伴。两个爱喝Google饮料的女孩。我们随时为你效劳。好吧，查尔斯有一个单人访谈，他在访谈中非常坦然地承认了这一点。
He's like, look, I know the effect I have on women. That's a meme. Yeah. It's so funny. Well, Aaron sure shared with us, you guys, that that talking head was inspired from a real interaction he had. He said there was an actor he was working with, no names. He wouldn't divulge the name, Big Star, who they were pitching a joke to.
他说，听着，我知道我对女性的影响力。这成了一个梗。是的。太有趣了。好吧，亚伦·舒尔跟我们分享过，各位，那个单人访谈的灵感来自于他的一次真实经历。他说他曾和一个演员合作过，不提名字了。他不会透露名字，是个大明星，他们当时正在向他推销一个笑话。
And the actor was like, this joke would never work because, I mean, I know the effect I have on women and Aaron saved that it went in his brain and Charles had it in a talking head. I really wish that we knew the actor, but Aaron, gentlemen that he is, did not say. Maybe if we took him out for a Scotch and Splenda, maybe he would tell us immediately after the scene. Kelly is not going to give up guys. And in the deleted scenes, there's a little bit of what I want to call a flirty in the
然后那个演员说，这个笑话绝对行不通，因为，我的意思是，我知道我对女性的影响力，亚伦把这句话记在了脑子里，查尔斯在单人访谈中就用了这句话。我真的很希望我们知道那个演员是谁，但亚伦作为一位绅士，没有说。也许如果我们请他去喝杯苏格兰威士忌加代糖，也许他会在场景拍摄结束后立刻告诉我们。凯利是不会放弃的，各位。在删减片段中，有一段我想称之为调情的内容，在
break room, excuse me, hello, hey, having a nice day here, great. You must be from drama juice. Oh, what's that? It's a juice company because you're a smoothie. Okay. I'm sorry. Why do I ever talk to shut up, shut up, shut up. So she has this really lame pickup line and then immediately just hates herself and goes
茶水间，不好意思，你好，嘿，今天过得不错吧，太棒了。你一定是从戏剧果汁公司来的吧。哦，那是什么？是一家果汁公司，因为你是个甜心（沙冰）。好吧。我很抱歉。我为什么要说话，闭嘴，闭嘴，闭嘴。所以她用了这个非常蹩脚的搭讪台词，然后立刻恨起自己来，缩到
in the corner and is like, why did I do that? Well this leads us into a scene that I will call awkward in the kitchen. Oh, so awkward. Michael is still trying to recruit people for his business and Andy does that thing, you know, that people do when they're uncomfortable. They either sing their answer or they do it accent. I think I'm the accent person. I sing stuff.
角落里，心想：我为什么要那么做？好吧，这就把我们带入了另一个我称之为厨房里的尴尬场景。哦，太尴尬了。迈克尔还在试图为他的公司招揽人手，而安迪做出了那种举动，你知道的，人们在感到不自在时会做的举动。他们要么把回答唱出来，要么用方言腔调说。我想我是那种用方言腔调的人。我喜欢把东西唱出来。
Yeah. When you don't want to like really tip your hand. Yeah. So Andy's like, oh, oh, interesting idea, like he does some ridiculous accent, but you would be like, that's a very interesting offer. Yeah. I mean, the other day I did it while we were working together, when we were working on that document.
是的。当你不想真正亮出底牌的时候。是的。所以安迪就说，哦，哦，有趣的想法，就像他用了某种荒谬的口音，但你会觉得，这是一个非常有趣的提议。是的。我的意思是，前几天我们在合作时我也这么做了，我们在处理那份文件的时候。
Oh yeah. I was like, this PDF editing is difficult. And then I was like, are you okay? Because it sounds like you're about to spiral. I was like, yeah. Well it gets only more cringey because now Dwight comes in, but Michael does not ask Dwight to join his company, but it is also clear that Dwight wouldn't say yes anyway. Yeah.
哦，是的。我说，这个PDF编辑太难了。然后我说，你还好吗？因为听起来你快要崩溃了。我说，是的。好吧，这变得越来越令人尴尬了，因为现在德怀特进来了，但迈克尔并没有邀请德怀特加入他的公司，不过显而易见的是，即便邀请了德怀特也不会答应。是的。
So he's like, I've got the farm and a thing and let's put a pin in it. Yeah. Let's definitely put a pin in that. Yeah. So we got a lot of mail about this kitchen scene. A lot of people felt like it was out of character for Dwight to not want to join Michael's paper company. And also people wondered why didn't Michael want him to join?
所以他就说，我有农场还有别的事，我们先把这事搁置一下。是的。我们绝对应该把这事搁置一下。是的。所以我们收到了很多关于这个厨房场景的邮件。很多人觉得德怀特不想加入迈克尔的纸业公司是不符合人物性格的。而且大家也想知道为什么迈克尔不想让他加入？
And I just didn't know if we wanted to discuss. I have my thoughts. Let me hear them. Dwight is a survivalist and he doesn't think Michael's company is going to survive. So ultimately, even though he loves Michael, he's not going to go somewhere where he won't survive, right? Yeah. So I think he's very practical, so he's not going to go with Michael.
我只是不知道我们是否想探讨一下。我有我的看法。说来听听。德怀特是个生存主义者，他认为迈克尔的公司无法生存下去。所以归根结底，尽管他爱迈克尔，但他不会去一个无法生存的地方，对吧？是的。所以我认为他非常务实，所以他不会跟迈克尔走。
But I'm not sure why Michael doesn't want Dwight. Do you have any thoughts? You know, that is a really good question. I definitely see why Dwight would say no, but why Michael doesn't ask, I'm not quite sure. Yeah. Do you guys have theories? Yeah.
但我不太确定为什么迈克尔不想要德怀特。你有什么想法吗？你知道，这真的是个好问题。我完全明白为什么德怀特会拒绝，但迈克尔为什么不邀请他，我就不太确定了。是的。你们有什么理论吗？是的。
Send us your theories. We'll revisit it. But Michael is going to ask Oscar. And the way he's going to do that is by putting a note in his sandwich, a piece of paper that he bites into. Don't worry, it's sterile. Just saying sterile doesn't mean it's sterile. I loved that line.
把你们的理论发给我们吧。我们会重新探讨的。但迈克尔打算去邀请奥斯卡。他打算用的方法是把一张纸条塞进奥斯卡的 三明治里，一张他咬了一口的纸条。别担心，这是无菌的。仅仅说无菌并不意味着它就是无菌的。我太喜欢这句台词了。
It's like just saying bankrupt doesn't mean you declared bankruptcy. Exactly. Michael gets Oscar to meet him outside. And Oscar immediately starts offering very practical advice about how most new businesses don't turn a profit for the first two years. And you know, can he afford that? Can he afford to make no money for two years? Right.
这就好比仅仅说破产并不意味着你已经宣布破产了一样。没错。迈克尔把奥斯卡叫到外面见面。奥斯卡立刻开始提供非常务实的建议，谈到大多数新公司在头两年内是如何无法实现盈利的。你知道的，他承担得起吗？他承担得起两年内赚不到钱吗？没错。
Well, Michael's like, hey, hey, stop convincing me, you got the job. With all your number lingo. But ultimately, Oscar's a no. And that means that he has to move on to Stanley, who he's going to stock outside the bathroom. Outside? He's inside. I guess outside the stall. I don't know how urinals work, but I imagine he walked up while he was just peeing because
好吧，迈克尔却说，嘿，嘿，别说服我了，你被录用了。满嘴的数字术语。但最终，奥斯卡拒绝了。这意味着他不得不去找斯坦利，他将在卫生间外面堵截他。外面？他在里面。我想是在隔间外面吧。我不知道小便池是怎么运作的，但我想他走过去的时候斯坦利正在小便，因为
Stanley's like, I'm urinating. Michael keeps talking to him. Stanley's like, no. Michael has then a very sad talking head where he's like, you know what? No one said yes to prom, but I still had a good time. Guess what? What? Pam, fix the copier.
斯坦利说，我在小便。迈克尔还在继续跟他说话。斯坦利说，不。迈克尔随后进行了一段非常悲伤的单人访谈，他说，你知道吗？没人答应去毕业舞会，但我还是玩得很开心。猜怎么着？什么？帕姆，修好了复印机。
After four hours, she did it. She didn't let it beat her. No, she did not. She knows everything about this machine. Phyllis is going to copy a piece of paper and Pam is like, did it work? How is it? And Phyllis is like, fine, fine. So this whole copier storyline felt very familiar to me.
四个小时后，她成功了。她没有向它低头。不，她没有。她对这台机器了如指掌。菲利斯要复印一张纸，帕姆就问，成功了吗？效果怎么样？菲利斯说，挺好，挺好。所以整条复印机的故事线让我感觉非常熟悉。
Having worked many temp jobs, having fixed many copiers in my real life. And it just felt to me like it was written by someone who also had this personal knowledge. Yeah. So I had to ask Aaron, have you had experience with copiers? You know, cause so many of his real life stories have wound up in our scripts like running past the speed meter. Yeah. And this whole copier story has so many details.
因为我做过很多临时工，在现实生活中修过很多复印机。我觉得这就好像是由一个同样拥有这种亲身经历的人写的一样。是的。所以我不得不问亚伦，你对复印机有什么经验吗？你知道的，因为他的许多现实生活中的故事都写进了我们的剧本里，比如超速测速仪。是的。而这个整条复印机的故事有这么多的细节。
So as it turns out, yes, yes. He told us that he tempt in a ton of offices when he was a struggling standup in New York and he quickly learned that if you could unjam the copier, you held the power. Yeah. And he actually said, quote, you were like an office magician, a David Copperfield opening the cabinet of mysteries. And only a person who has done the copier thing, I feel like totally gets it. So I totally get it.
事实证明，是的，是的。他告诉我们，当他在纽约做一个苦命的单口喜剧演员时，他在大量的办公室里做过临时工，他很快就了解到，只要你能修好卡纸的复印机，你就掌握了权力。是的。他甚至还说，原话是：“你就像一个办公室魔术师，一个打开神秘橱柜的大卫·科菲尔珀。”我觉得只有做过修复印机这事的人才能完全理解。所以我完全能理解。
He said that he would actually copy the user manuals and take them home and read them over the week. That's the part that really got me. He would like learn everything from the manual. Aaron, I feel you, thank you for writing this runner for Pam because I was able to draw on a lot of my real life experience when it came to performing this copier story. Well, I don't know, did Michael leave the fakey order form in the copier? Charles finds it.
他说他甚至会把用户手册复印下来，带回家，花上一周的时间阅读。就是这部分真正打动了我。他会像这样把手册里的所有东西都学会。亚伦，我理解你，谢谢你为帕姆写了这段支线剧情，因为在表演这段复印机的故事时，我能够借鉴很多我现实生活中的经验。好吧，我不知道，迈克尔是不是把那份假的订单留在复印机里了？查尔斯发现了它。
How does he find it? We don't know. But he's going to get Hank and they're going to escort him out the building. I am sorry, I am not sure that there is a recurring character that I love more than Hugh Dane as Hank. I know. I know. When Michael's like, Hank, come on, escort Charles out and Hank's like, come on, man.
他是怎么发现的？我们不知道。但他要把汉克叫来，他们要把他护送出大楼。抱歉，我不确定我是否能找到一个比扮演汉克的休·丹恩更让我喜欢的常驻角色了。我知道。我知道。当迈克尔说，汉克，来吧，护送查尔斯出去，汉克却说，拜托，老兄。
I know. Just come on. He's so good. So good. Michael really wanted to make a farewell speech. Charles is not going to have that. And everyone watches him as he leaves. And he's like yelling things from his car, right?
我知道。就，拜托。他太棒了。太棒了。迈克尔真的很想发表一篇告别演讲。查尔斯可不容许他这么做。所有人都看着他离开。他还在车里大喊大叫，对吧？
He's yelling from the parking lot and everyone's looking down and they're like, what's he saying? We can't hear what he's saying. This is what it said in the script. All right. Michael walks toward his car. Everybody watches from the conference room above. Michael stops at his car and looks up at the dundermifflin windows.
他在停车场大喊大叫，所有人都往下看，心想：他在喊什么？我们听不见他在喊什么。剧本里是这样写的。好的。迈克尔走向他的车。大家从上方的会议室里看着。迈克尔在车旁停下，抬头看着邓德米夫林办公室的窗户。
And then he yells this, this is it, this is goodbye, forever, it's such a nice day out here, freedom. I'm already so happy. I can do anything I want right now. I'm going to go for coffee. That is what was in the script. And then it says he screeches his tires and drives off. The camera follows his car.
然后他大喊大叫：就是这样，这就是永别了，外面天气真好啊，自由了。我已经这么高兴了。我现在想干什么就能干什么。我要去喝杯咖啡。剧本里就是这么写的。然后上面写着他猛踩油门轮胎尖叫着开走了。镜头跟着他的车。
Michael parks just a short distance around the corner, gets out of his car, sneaks back into the parking lot and into the building. We get to hear a lot of people's opinions on Michael leaving. My favorite is probably Toby. He says, Michael is like a movie on a plane. Not great, but something to watch. And then when the movie's over, you're like, now what? Yes.
迈克尔把车停在街角不远处的短距离内，下了车，偷偷溜回停车场和建筑物里。我们听到了许多人对迈克尔离开的看法。我最喜欢的可能是托比。他说，迈克尔就像飞机上放的电影。虽说不上多好，但也算个消遣。然后电影一结束，你就会想：接下来呢？是的。
BJ wrote that talking head, very funny, and we got a piece of mail about it. What? Someone wrote in, and I'm so sorry I did not write down your name, to say that a missed opportunity in this episode was Toby conducting Michael's exit interview. Oh, wouldn't you have loved to see that? And I mentioned it to Aaron, and Aaron said, ah, but he was escorted out. They like to believe that if Michael hadn't been escorted out, he would have had his exit interview with Toby before he left.
BJ写的那段单人访谈非常搞笑，我们收到了一封关于它的邮件。什么？有人写信来——非常抱歉我没有记下你的名字——说这一集里错失的一个良机是让托比来对迈克尔进行离职面谈。哦，你难道不想看看那个吗？我把它提给亚伦时，亚伦说，啊，但他被护送出去了。他们愿意相信，如果迈克尔没有被护送出去的话，他在离开前肯定会和托比进行离职面谈的。
Plus they had written a pretty great Michael Toby scene where Toby helps him with his resume that didn't make it in. Yes. And as everyone is having these really funny talking heads, Creed had one that was in the shooting draft, and it didn't make it in, and I have to read it to you. Okay. Creed says, old Creedie outlives yet another boss, time to put a marble in the box. And then Creed pulls out a cigar box out from his desk and puts a marble in it.
另外，他们其实写了一场非常棒的迈克尔与托比的戏，托比帮他修改简历，但最后被剪掉了。是的。正当每个人都在发表这些非常有趣的单人访谈时，拍摄剧本里其实有克里德的一段访谈，但最后被剪掉了，我必须读给你们听。好的。克里德说，老克里德又熬走了一个老板，是时候往盒子里放一颗弹珠了。然后克里德从办公桌里拿出一个雪茄盒，放进去一颗弹珠。
There are four marbles in that box. What is that? What is that? Is that amazing? Well, like you said, Angela, Michael is not leaving. He actually army crawls through the front door, through the office. He goes over to accounting. This was a really fun scene for us to shoot.
那个盒子里已经有四颗弹珠了。那是什么？那是什么？这难道不神奇吗？好吧，正如你所说，安吉拉，迈克尔并没有离开。他实际上通过前门匍匐爬进了办公室。他径直走向会计部。对我们来说，拍这场戏真的很有趣。
It was really hard not to laugh. We played around with how I shut the drawer, and I ultimately shut it with my foot, and it was just like so fun. Steve really tore up his elbows and his knees, though, doing that. He got like a rug burn. Yes. And Randy told us that they offered him elbow and knee pads, and Steve was like, it's fine. I'll do it.
要忍住不笑真的很难。我们尝试了各种我关抽屉的方式，最后我用脚把它关上了，真的太有趣了。不过，史蒂夫做那个动作时真的把手肘和膝盖都擦破了。他弄出了像地毯灼伤一样的伤口。是的。兰迪告诉我们，他们曾提出给他提供护肘和护膝，但史蒂夫却说，没关系。我能行。
And he did two takes without the elbow and knee pads, and he totally tore up his elbows and knees. He was so committed. Also, Randy told us, you know, when he throws that highlighter at Jim? Yeah. Yeah. That was not a real highlighter. That was a fakey highlighter.
结果他在没有戴护肘和护膝的情况下拍了两条，手肘和膝盖彻底擦破了。他太投入了。另外，兰迪还告诉我们，你知道当他把记号笔扔向吉姆时吗？是的。是的。那不是一支真正的记号笔。那是一支假的记号笔。
Oh, so it wouldn't like hurt someone? Yes. When Michael throws the pen at Toby's forehead, and Phil had to make a rubber pen, Phil had to make a rubber highlighter, and it cost $850. Whoa. Yep. Michael wants everyone to go with him, and he starts to pull at Phyllis' chair. And you see it from the point of view of Charles, right?
哦，这样就不会伤害到别人了？是的。当迈克尔把笔扔向托比的前额时，菲尔不得不制作了一支橡胶笔，菲尔不得不制作了一支橡胶记号笔，这花费了850美元。哇。没错。迈克尔想让所有人都跟他一起走，他开始拉菲利斯的椅子。你是从查尔斯的视角看到的，对吧？
You see Phyllis kind of like lurching, right? Yeah. To the side. If you watch the bloopers, you guys, and I remember this happening. The first time we did this scene, Steve yanks on Phyllis' chair, and she fell right out of it. Oh, yeah. I remember that.
你看到菲利斯有点踉踉跄跄的，对吧？是的。往旁边倒去。如果你看了花絮，各位，我还记得这件事发生过。我们第一次拍这场戏时，史蒂夫猛拉菲利斯的椅子，她直接从椅子上摔了下去。哦，对。我记得那个。
And they didn't stop rolling. You know, Michael just goes, oh my God, Phyllis, are you okay? Are you okay? And Phyllis kind of snorts, laughs, and she says, yes, yes. But it's in the bloopers, and it's great. Now, Charles is going to find Michael. Yeah. He comes out of his office, and they have this really awkward exchange.
而且他们没有停机。你知道的，迈克尔只是说，哦天哪，菲利斯，你还好吗？你还好吗？菲利斯有点嗤之以鼻地笑了，然后她说，好，好。但那在花絮里，非常精彩。现在，查尔斯要去找迈克尔了。是的。他从办公室里出来，他们进行了这场非常尴尬的交流。
Yeah, like where it's going to get physical. All right. In the deleted scenes, Jenna. Charles finds Michael stealing office supplies in a box, and chases him through the kitchen. Michael drops the box of supplies to like throw him off, you know? Maybe Charles will trip over it. And then he like, last ditch effort just grabs the big container of cheese balls and makes a run for it.
对，就像是要动真格的一样。好吧，在删减片段中，珍娜。查尔斯发现迈克尔在一个盒子里偷办公室用品，并在厨房里追赶他。迈克尔扔下那箱办公用品来分散他的注意力，你知道的？也许查尔斯会被它绊倒。然后他做出了垂死挣扎般的最后努力，直接抓起一大桶奶酪球，拔腿就跑。
Oh my gosh. That's why we're going to have cheese balls later. Yes. In Michael's paper company. Because in the deleted scenes, that's what he leaves with, is the cheese balls. I love it. I know. I wish it had made it in.
哦天哪。这就是为什么我们稍后会有奶酪球的原因。是的。在迈克尔的纸业公司里。因为在删减片段中，他带走的东西就是奶酪球。我太喜欢了。我知道。我真希望它能被剪进正片。
But for me, when Michael's like, who's with me? Who's coming with me? This is his Jerry Maguire moment. Instead of a goldfish, it's a bunch of cheese balls. That is perfect. I thought we had to hear Jerry's moment, and then Michael's moment. This moment will be the moment of something real, and fun, and inspiring in this God-forsaken business, and we will do it together.
但对我来说，当迈克尔说：谁跟我走？谁要跟我走？这就是他的《甜心先生》时刻。手里拿的不是金鱼，而是一桶奶酪球。这简直绝了。我觉得我们必须听听杰瑞的高光时刻，然后是迈克尔的高光时刻。这一刻将是这一行中真实、有趣且鼓舞人心的某一刻，我们将一起做到这一点。
Who's coming with me? Who's coming with me? Who's coming with me? Who's coming with me besides Flipper here? I will go with you. And now, for Michael and Pam's moment. This is your future. Hello.
谁跟我走？谁跟我走？谁跟我走？除了这里的飞车侠（Flipper），还有谁跟我走？我跟你走。现在，轮到迈克尔和帕姆的高光时刻了。这就是你的未来。你好。
This is your future. You are older, and you are very happy now, because you went with Michael Scott, right? So everybody, come on down. Now let's just crawl out of here together, all right? Come on. Are you doing your best here? Are you being the best that you can be? All right, everybody, who's going to go with me, I want you to stop your foot.
这就是你的未来。你变老了，你现在非常幸福，因为你跟着迈克尔·斯科特走了，对吧？所以大家，快来吧。现在让我们一起从这里爬出去，好吗？来吧。你在这里做到最好了吗？你在尽你所能做到最好吗？好了，各位，谁要跟我走，我要你们跺跺脚。
Oh no. What? I'm going with him. I mean, come on. Oh, it was so Jerry Maguire. By the way, I forgot about the goldfish in Jerry Maguire, and I'll have you know that when we get to Michael Scott Paper Company, not only do we have those cheese puffs, but Michael has a goldfish on his desk.
哦不。什么？我跟他走。我的天，拜托。哦，这太像《甜心先生》了。顺便说一句，我都忘了《甜心先生》里的那条金鱼了，而且我要让你们知道，当我们来到迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司时，不仅有那些奶酪泡芙，迈克尔的桌上还有一条金鱼。
Come on. Yep. Well, fans were very split on this episode. A lot of people loved this turn of events of Michael starting his paper company and Pam going with him, but other people really thought that it was selfish of Pam to quit without talking to Jim first. Well, we talked to Aaron Sure about this, and he said two things. First of all, he said in a future episode, spoiler alert, Vikram from the telemarketing
拜托。没错。好吧，粉丝们对这一集的看法非常不一。很多人喜欢迈克尔创办自己的纸业公司、帕姆跟着他走的这个剧情反转，但也有人觉得帕姆在没有先跟吉姆商量的情况下就辞职太自私了。好吧，我们跟亚伦·舒尔谈过这件事，他说两点。首先，他说在未来的剧集中，剧透警告，来自电话营销公司的维克拉姆将加入迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司。是的。
firm is going to join Michael Scott Paper Company. Yes. I wrote this talking head for Vikram that got cut, but it explained why Vikram decided to join Michael Scott Paper Company, and it went like this. When you put your telemarketing career on the line, you haven't put much on the line. And Aaron said he felt like that kind of summed up Pam as well. Right. That Pam wasn't quitting much of a job at all.
我为维克拉姆写过这段被剪掉的单人访谈，但它解释了维克拉姆为什么决定加入迈克尔·斯科特纸业公司的原因，它是这么说的。当你把电话营销生涯押上的时候，你其实并没有押上多少东西。亚伦说，他觉得这也同样适用于帕姆。没错。也就是说帕姆其实并没有辞掉多大不了的工作。
Well, if she could be replaced by some invisible scotch tape. Yeah. Right. Yeah. There was also a line that Aaron wrote to explain this business of Pam not talking to Jim before making this decision, a little couplet of dialogue that got cut, where Jim said to Pam, shouldn't we have talked about this first? And Pam said, you blindsided me with a house, and Jim said, you're right, I'll bring your
嗯，如果她可以被一些看不见的苏格兰胶带代替的话。是的。没错。是的。亚伦还写了一句台词来解释帕姆在做出这个决定之前没有和吉姆商量这回事，一小段被剪掉的对话是这样的：吉姆对帕姆说，难道我们不应该先商量一下吗？帕姆说，你用一栋房子打了我的伏击。吉姆说，你说得对，我把你的东西拿回家。
stuff home. So he did address it, but it ended up getting cut. I think it was the right move to cut it, because it seems like, I don't know, a real thing Pam is holding on to that I don't think she is. No, I don't think so. As soon as Jim showed her the house, she loved it. She felt cared for and loved. She took it on, and I think she's been very happy ever since.
所以他确实谈到了这一点，但最后还是被剪掉了。我觉得剪掉是正确的决定，因为看起来，我不知道，好像帕姆一直在怀恨在心似的，我觉得她并没有。不，我不这么认为。吉姆一给她看那房子，她就爱上了。她感受到了被照顾和被爱。她接受了它，而且我认为她从那以后一直非常幸福。
So I'm glad that they didn't pin that as some sort of lingering resentment for Pam. Yeah. Pam catches up to Michael in the parking lot. She says she's coming along, but she wants to be a salesman, not a receptionist. And Jim's kind of surprised by that. He's like, oh, okay. Yeah. And everyone is gathered again up in the conference room, and they're looking down as Pam and Michael
所以我很高兴他们没有把这定性为帕姆某种挥之不去的怨恨。是的。帕姆在停车场追上了迈克尔。她说她要一起去，但她想做销售员，而不是前台。吉姆对此有点惊讶。他说，哦，好吧。是的。大家又聚在楼上的会议室里，看着帕姆和迈克尔
walk away. And as they're walking away, you can see the doubt. You see this change of them being from triumphant to kind of doubt. Right. Well, a lot of people liken this ending to the ending of the graduate, and spoiler alert to anyone who's never seen the graduate. But at the end of the movie, the character of Benjamin who's played by Dustin Hoffman crashes the wedding of his love Elaine, and the two of them are running away from the
走开。当他们走开时，你能看出那种怀疑。你看出了他们从意气风发到产生怀疑的转变。好吧，很多人把这个结局比作《毕业生》的结局，向所有没看过《毕业生》的人剧透警告。但在电影结尾，由达斯汀·霍夫曼饰演的角色本杰明大闹了他爱人伊莱恩的婚礼，他们两个从
church. They're laughing together, and then they jump onto this city bus, and it's always just so exciting. And they take their seat, and while they're sitting there, their expressions kind of slowly change. It's a really famous scene. It's so good. Well, in the script, our stage direction for this scene was this.
教堂跑出来。他们一起大笑着，然后他们跳上了一辆城市公交车，那种感觉总是那么激动人心。他们找了个座位坐下，当他们坐在那里时，他们的表情慢慢地发生了变化。这是一个非常著名的场景。太棒了。好吧，在剧本里，我们对这个场景的舞台指导是这样的。
Jim waves as Michael and Pam walk out together. We stay on their faces as they transition from fantasy to reality. So I was not thinking of the graduate when we shot this. I was thinking of a different scene from the movie, The Heartbreak Kid with Charles Groton. Have you seen it? I mean, a long time ago. Well, again, I guess, spoiler alert, at the end of this movie, he's finally married the woman of his dreams, Sybil Shepard, he's been chasing her through the whole movie.
吉姆在迈克尔和帕姆一起走出去时挥手致意。镜头停留在他们的脸上，看着他们从幻想过渡到现实。所以我们在拍这场戏时并没有想到《毕业生》。我想的是电影《绝代佳人》中的另一个场景，查尔斯·格罗丁主演的。你看过吗？我的意思是，那是很久以前的事了。好吧，再次，我想，剧透警告，在这部电影的结尾，他终于娶了他梦寐以求的女人西碧尔·谢帕德，他在整部电影中一直在追求她。
He sits down at a couch at their reception, and then you just see this sort of like malaise wash over his face, and he's like, what now? Because for him, it's all about the joy of the pursuit, but now he did it, and you can tell he's already restless. I thought of that moment, because I always think that's such a perfect moment of acting. I mean, he's so good in that movie. But anyway. Well, I will tell you that Tom Cruise and Renee Zellweger in The Elevator, holding
他坐在他们招待会的沙发上，然后你就能看到这种类似烦躁不安的情绪涌上他的面孔，他就像在说：接下来呢？因为对他来说，一切都在于追求的乐趣，但现在他成功了，你能看出他已经开始坐立不安了。我想到了那一刻，因为我一直认为那是演技的绝佳时刻。我的意思是，他在那部电影里太棒了。不过无论如何。好吧，我要告诉你们的是，汤姆·克鲁斯和蕾妮·齐薇格在电梯里，手里拿着
a goldfish, also have a moment like that because I rewatched the movie last night. Well, this episode ends with something I absolutely love. There's a conference room scene. Charles is telling everyone we've lost some employees, we're going to have to do some shifting around, and this is so great. Everyone's reactions are so good. He's like, you know what, Kevin, you're going to be answering phones at reception. Everyone in the room is like, what?
一条金鱼，也有过类似的一刻，因为我昨晚又重温了这部电影。好吧，这一集的结尾有一个我非常喜欢的桥段。有一个会议室的场景。查尔斯在告诉大家我们失去了一些员工，我们将不得不做一些人员调动，而这实在是太棒了。所有人的反应都太好了。他说，你知道吗，凯文，你要去前台接电话。房间里的所有人都心想：什么？
I know. Kevin? I know. I am very much in the foreground of this shot. That was on purpose, because they wanted me to react, obviously. And then he says he's going to put Stanley, who's doing his crossword, barely awake, in charge of productivity. Dwight is like, are you kidding me?
我知道。凯文？我知道。我在这场戏的显眼位置。那是故意的，因为他们显然想让我做出反应。然后他说他要把正打着填字游戏、几乎快要睡着的斯坦利调去负责生产效率。德怀特就像是在说：你在开玩笑吧？
Kevin said he pitched that idea of having Charles put Kevin in charge of the phones, which is going to pay off beautifully in the cold open of next week's episode. But he said it just makes him giggle to think that, like, Charles' big power move after Michael leaves is putting Kevin in charge of the phones. Like, he's like, I got this place. Yeah, yeah. I know what to do. Speaking of the next episode, ironically, it did not air for two weeks.
凯文说他提出了这个想法，让查尔斯安排凯文负责接听电话，这将在下周剧集的片头前情提要中带来绝佳的回报。但他说，一想到查尔斯在迈克尔离开后的重大权力之举竟然是让凯文负责接电话，他就忍不住咯咯发笑。就像是，他在想：这个地方我罩着。是的，是的。我知道该怎么做。说到下一集，讽刺的是，它两周后才播。
Oh, no way. Yes. There was a break. I just thought that was really funny. People had to really wait. Two weeks. Yeah. This was a big cliffhanger.
哦，不会吧。是的。中间停播了两周。我只是觉得这真的很有趣。大家真的得等。两周。是的。这是一个巨大的悬念。
Also, this is the last episode that Pam was a receptionist ever on the office. She never returns to the receptionist desk. Let's finish our Scotch and Splenda. To Pam, our IP receptionist. I know. Next up, Selzman. To Pam. I didn't know that either.
另外，这也是帕姆在《办公室》里最后一次担任前台。她再也没有回到前台的座位上。让我们喝完我们的苏格兰威士忌加代糖。致帕姆，我们不可替代的前台。我知道。接下来，塞尔兹曼。敬帕姆。我以前也不知道这一点。
Wow. When we filmed this episode, I didn't know. I didn't know that you didn't know at the time. Yeah. Well, we didn't know what was going to happen. We didn't. Wow. I should have worn my t-shirt today that says I would save the receptionist.
哇。我们拍这一集的时候，我并不知道。我当时不知道你不知道。是的。好吧，我们不知道接下来会发生什么。我们真的不知道。哇。我今天本该穿上那件印有“我会拯救前台”的T恤。
Hmm. Yeah. Well, listen, there were a lot of other receptionists that come along, but Pam is always going to be our favorite. Well, thank you, lady. At least you're on office, ladies. Come on. Thank you so much.
嗯哼。是的。好吧，听着，后来还有很多其他的前台，但帕姆永远是我们的最爱。好吧，谢谢你，女士。至少你是办公室女士。拜托。非常感谢。
That was two weeks. Next week is Dream Team. I can't wait to talk about it. Please don't bring any Scotch and Splenda. We can't do it. We can't have a Scotch and Splenda and do that podcast. You know what I'll bring next week? A giant pile of French toast.
那是两周。下周是《梦幻团队》。我迫不及待地想聊聊它了。请不要带任何苏格兰威士忌加代糖。我们做不到。我们不能喝着苏格兰威士忌加代糖来录这个播客。你知道我下周要带什么吗？一大堆法式吐司。
Oh, gosh. Don't bring that either. Listen, thank you so much to Erin Shore and Randy Cordray for giving us all the inside details on this episode. We'll see you next week. Bye, you guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
哦，天哪。那个也别带。听着，非常感谢亚伦·舒尔和兰迪·科德雷为我们提供关于这一集的所有的内部细节。我们下周见。再见，各位。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. All rights reserved. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目由科迪·费舍尔执行制作。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾因斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿创作的《Rubber Tree》。想要收听无广告版本的《办公室女士》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。保留所有权利。本集尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。